didn't file my taxes for 2020 and 2021 U
probably 80% of that was um obviously
commission so I did dumb uh I know I
need to file those now obviously and I'm
gonna owe quite a bit I was just going
to see if I can maybe get some um advice
on how to go about doing that in the the
least harmful way ouch okay here here's
the thing not paying taxes is not a
criminal act not filing taxes is a
criminal act that's what's weird we do
not have a debtor's prison they don't
put people in jail for not paying their
taxes but they do put people in jail
about 2500 a year for failure to file
okay so that's where that's the danger
that you're in I'm more concerned about
that than I am the payment plan I don't
think you're in trouble and because 99%
of the time that you're not some Pol not
some public figure that you come and
self F you know you catch up your
filings they're just all late um you
don't get into any criminal issues